why not just for one day anytime Mel you  know what you should do but you don't  feel like it why don't you just count  backwards and see what happens like NASA  launches a rock at 54321 and that's what  I did yeah and I haven't looked back I  don't give a [ __ ] how stupid you think  this is I want you to try it I want you  to share it with people because  interrupting the patterns of thought and  behavior that are holding you back and  pushing yourself to take action or to  think something different it is the only  way you're going to change the single  most positive and effective tool is the  five second rule because it is simple  you remember it and it immediately  interrupts the negative and suicidal  ideations that torture people and  speaking of suicide we know of 111  people who have stopped themselves from  taking their lives by 54321 asking for  help